IS OFF HIS ROCKER.
ALL RIGHT, TUCKER, GREAT SHOW AS
ALWAYS.
WELCOME TO "HANNITY" AS WE KICK
OFF WHAT WILL NOW BE AN EXCITING
BUSY NEWS WEEK AND PROBABLY A
WEEK OF A BOOMERANG.
WE START THOUGH TONIGHT WITH A
FOX NEWS ALERT.
BECAUSE AT THIS HOUR, THE
HOSTILE OR RAINY RIDGE DREAM IS
ON A MISSION TO DESTABILIZE THE
FREE WORLD.
THEY STAKED CLAIM THAT THEY HAD
A SECRET CIA'S SPY RING OF THE
PRESIDENT AND SECRETARY POMPEO,
CALLING IT LIES, PROPAGANDA.
WE WILL HAVE A FULL REPORT
THROUGHOUT THE EVENING TONIGHT.
BUT FIRST, LIARS, CONSPIRACY
THEORIST, AND CON ARTIST IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND THE MEDIA,
THEY ARE BREATHLESSLY
HYSTERICALLY ANXIOUSLY AWAITING
ROBERT MUELLER'S PUBLIC
TESTIMONY.
THIS WEDNESDAY STARTING AT
8:30 A.M., IT WILL BE RIGHT HERE
ON THE FOX NEWS CHANNEL,
ROBERT MUELLER WILL APPEAR
BEFORE TWO HOUSE COMMITTEE IS
LED BY TWO OF THE BIGGEST
POLITICAL HACKS, TWO OF THE
BIGGEST LIARS IN THE
UNITED STATES CONGRESS.
OF COURSE THE ONE, THE COWARDLY
ADAM SCHIFF, THE ONE THAT WE
HAVE ON TAPE ACTUALLY CONSPIRING
AND TRYING TO GET INFORMATION
FROM THE RUSSIANS, AND
JERRY NADLER, AS YOU KNOW,
SCHIFF AND NADLER, TWO
CONSPIRACY THEORY US THAT ONLY
PANDER TO THE WING OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY WHICH APPEARS
TO BE THE WHOLE PARTY.
AND THEY ARE THE BIGGEST
SPOKESPEOPLE IN THE MEDIA MOB,
AND THEIR FRIENDS GO TO BAT FOR
THEM EVERY DAY.
AND TWO PLUS THE YEARS, NO
EVIDENCE.
THEY'VE BEEN TELLING PEOPLE
AGAIN AND AGAIN AND AGAIN, YOU,
WE, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE THAT THE
DULY ELECTED PRESIDENT WAS A
RUSSIAN OPS SPREADING LIES, A
HOAX, CONSPIRING WITH RUSSIA.
PUSHING ONE CONSPIRACY THEORY,
ONE HOAX RIGHT AFTER ANOTHER.
ONE LIE AFTER ANOTHER.
PROMISING ONE SMOKING GUN AFTER
ANOTHER.
WE NOW HAVE FOUR SEPARATE
INVESTIGATIONS ALL OF THEM,
INCLUDING THE MUELLER REPORT
HAVE DETERMINED THAT
TRUMP-RUSSIA COLLUSION NEVER
HAPPENED.
LET'S GO TO THE MUELLER REPORT
ITSELF.
IT CONCLUDED "THE INVESTIGATION
DID NOT ESTABLISH THAT MEMBERS
OF THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN CONSPIRED
OR COORDINATED WITH THE RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT IN ITS ELECTION
INTERFERENCE ACTIVITIES."
THEY DID NOT CONSPIRE.
THAT IS THE FOURTH SEPARATE
INVESTIGATION.
NOW THEY WANT AN INVESTIGATION
NUMBER FIVE, SIX, SEVEN, EIGHT,
NINE, AND TEN.
NO COLLUSION, NO CONSPIRACY.
NO OBSTRUCTION.
NO UNDERLYING CRIME, AND THIS
PRESIDENT AND HIS ENTIRE
ADMINISTRATION, EVERYBODY THAT
WAS ASKED, COOPERATED.
THAT'S RIGHT, THE PRESIDENT GAVE
ANSWERS.
EVERYBODY IN THE WHITE HOUSE,
APPEARING BEFORE ONE COMMITTEE
AFTER ANOTHER.
GOING TO THE SPECIAL COUNSEL ONE
ALL ENCOURAGE, BY THE WAY, ALL
CAMPAIGN, ALL WHITE HOUSE STAFF
TO TESTIFY, AND THEY ALL DATED.
NOT A SINGLE INSTANCE OF
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE WAS EVER
APPLIED DURING THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL PROBE.
OH, HOW IS THAT OBSTRUCTIONIST?
EVEN THE WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL DON
MCGANN, THIS TIMING IS INSANE.
EVEN HE WAS ALLOWED TO TESTIFY
FOR OVER 30 HOURS, AND
INDEPENDENT COUNSEL, FORMER
INDEPENDENT COUNSEL KEN STARR
CALLED THIS ADMINISTRATIONS
COOPERATION UNPRECEDENTED.
AND IT WAS.
THE PRESIDENT EXPRESSED
FRUSTRATION ABOUT TO THE ONGOING
WITCH HUNT THAT HE WAS FOUND
INNOCENT OF FOR A FOURTH TIME?
YES, HE DID.
I DON'T BLAME HIM.
DID HE COMPLAIN ABOUT THE TIME
THE ADMINISTRATION WAS FORCED TO
DEDICATE TO AN ABSOLUTE
CONSPIRACY THEORY, A HOAX AND
LIES?
YES, I THINK ANY NORMAL PERSON
WOULD FEEL THAT WAY.
BUT HE NEVER FIRED
ROBERT MUELLER OR ACTING AG
ROSENSTEIN, HE ASSISTED IN THE
INVESTIGATION, AND ASK THOSE
AROUND HIM TO IS CYST IN THE
INVESTIGATION.
ANYWAY THEY COULD.
AND GENERAL BARR, THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL ROD ROSENSTEIN,
THE OFFICE OF LEGAL COUNSEL,
THEY LOOKED AT IT, THEY DECIDED
PRETTY MUCH IN MINUTES NO
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE EITHER.
ROBERT MUELLER HIMSELF ADMITTED,
NO OBSTRUCTION CHARGES OR
RECOMMENDED BY HIS OFFICE OF
SPECIAL COUNSEL, BECAUSE IT WAS
NOT SUFFICIENT EVIDENCE OF
OBSTRUCTION, JUST BECAUSE YOU
CANNOT EXAMINE RIGHT DOES NOT
MEAN THAT THERE ARE EXAMPLES OF
OBSTRUCTION.
AS A REGARDS TO THE LEGAL
PRECEDENT, THE DOJ POLICY OR
CONSTITUTIONAL ISSUES REGARDING
WHETHER OR NOT A SITTING
PRESIDENT CAN BE CHARGED WITH A
CRIME.
OVER THE WEEKEND, THE COWARDLY
LIAR SCHIFF, NADLER, THEY WERE
LIVING IN AN ALTERNATIVE
UNIVERSE, ALTERNATES REALITY.
ONCE AGAIN LYING FOR POLITICAL
GAIN.
AND ONCE AGAIN GENERATING FALSE
HOPE, AND EXPECTATIONS THAT
DONALD TRUMP WILL BE TAKEN OUT
OF THE WHITE HOUSE IN HANDCUFFS,
OR IMPEACHED, OR WORSE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> IT HAS BEEN CLEAR FROM
BOB MUELLER THAT HE FELT AND THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT FEELS BOUND
BY THIS OPPOSITE LEGAL COUNSEL
OPINION THAT YOU CAN'T INDICT A
SITTING PRESIDENT.
BUT HE IS ESSENTIALLY UNINDICTED
COCONSPIRATOR AND HAS BEEN
IDENTIFIED AS A INDIVIDUAL ONE.
TO SPEAK OF THE REPORT PRESENTS
SUBSTANTIAL EVIDENCE THAT THE
PRESIDENT IS GUILTY OF HIGH CRIE
PRESIDENT IS GUILTY OF HIGH CRIS
PRESIDENT IS GUILTY OF HIGH CRIA
PRESIDENT IS GUILTY OF HIGH CRID
MISDEMEANORS.
AND WE HAVE TO PRESENT, OR LET
MUELLER PRESENT THOSE FACTS TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND SEE
WHERE WE GO FROM THERE.
TO THE ADMINISTRATION MUST BE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
AND NO PRESIDENT CAN BE ABOVE
THE LAW.
>> Sean: HE IS NOT AN
UNINDICTED COCONSPIRATOR, AND
NO, IF YOU READ THE
CONSTITUTION, NOTHING THAT YOU
ARE TALKING ABOUT REPRESENTS HIG
ARE TALKING ABOUT REPRESENTS HIH
ARE TALKING ABOUT REPRESENTS HIC
ARE TALKING ABOUT REPRESENTS HII
ARE TALKING ABOUT REPRESENTS HIE
ARE TALKING ABOUT REPRESENTS HIS
ARE TALKING ABOUT REPRESENTS HIO
ARE TALKING ABOUT REPRESENTS HIR
MISDEMEANORS.
NONE OF IT.
AND FOR DEMOCRATS, MUELLER'S
TESTIMONY IS NOT ABOUT SEEKING
THE TRUTH.
THEY DON'T WANT JUSTICE.
THEY WANT ANOTHER BITE OF THE
APPLE.
THE FIRST FOUR TIMES THAT
FAILED.
THEY WANT IT RIGHT.
MAYBE THEY BELIEVE THEIR OWN
LIVES AT THIS POINT.
INSTEAD AS THE "L.A. TIMES"
POINTED OUT, THE LAST DITCH
SMEAR EFFORT AGAINST
DONALD TRUMP IS POLITICALLY
MOTIVATED.
AND IT IS.
AFTER ALL, THE SPECIAL REPORTER
HAS BEEN OUT THERE FOR MONTHS.
MUELLER SAID HIS WRITING WILL
SPEAK FOR ITSELF.
THAT WILL BE HIS INTRODUCTION,
HIS OPENING COMMENTS ON
WEDNESDAY.
HE SAID THAT ANY TESTIMONY WOULD
MERELY ECHO WHAT WAS IN THE
REPORT.
IN OTHER WORDS, WE WILL LEARN
NOTHING.
WE WILL LEARN IF ROBERT MUELLER
IS A MAN OF HIS WORD OR IF YOU
WILL FLIP-FLOP AND FAIL AND HAVE
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR BAIL
THEM OUT AGAIN.
BECAUSE A 9.5 MINUTE PRESS
CONFERENCE WAS A DISASTER FOR
HIM.
EITHER WAY, REPUBLICANS, THEY
HAVE AN AMAZING OPPORTUNITY TO
SEEK ANSWERS ON SOME VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUES AND QUESTIONS.
TOMORROW NIGHT ON THIS PROGRAM,
I AM GOING TO GIVE A TUTORIAL TO
THOSE IN CONGRESS ON THE
REPUBLICAN SIDE THAT WILL HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO QUESTION
MR. MUELLER.
I WILL GIVE YOU MY QUESTIONS,
AND ALSO THE WAY THAT I WOULD
ASK THEM AND THE FOLLOW-UPS THAT
SHOULD BE IMMEDIATE.
YOU ONLY HAVE 5 MINUTES.
YOU HAVE TO MAKE IT COUNT.
I WILL EXPLAIN HOW I WOULD DO IT
IF YOU'RE INTERESTED.
WHEN WE COME BACK TONIGHT AT
LATER IN THE PROGRAM,
SARA CARTER, GREGG JARRETT WILL
BREAK DOWN EVERY QUESTION THAT
ROBERT MUELLER MUST BE ASKED BY
THE REPUBLICANS AT THE HEARING.